an average human farts enough in one day
to fill up a party balloon I think you
could fill up a whole bouquet of him oh
dude I could have my own
business wait how great of a business
would that be I was just about to say
fart balloons yeah so it's like but it's
like a prank oh yeah but it's like one
of those like telegrams where you like
hire someone to walk up and deliver like
a note but instead they pop a fart
balloon or they let it go into someone's
face yeah or you tell some tell tell
somebody that it's helium but it's fart
and they suck it in hilarious but I
think if like it's like a it's like one
the telegrams where you go to the door
and be like hey so here's a cake for
your birthday and they got you some
balloons jokes on you and then you just
open it and just let it spew in them in
their face I think if you can combine
fart with helium because you couldn't do
pure fart because it wouldn't float
correct but if you did mostly helium
little bit of fart does that float Matt
science you seem smarter than us yeah so
it would have it would have to be like
great joke it would have to be like a
7030 mix or something like that where
there's more helium than we are 100%
helium farting somebody 100%